thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's going on guys welcome to amigos
code my name is nelson and in this
course
i'm going to teach you everything you
need to know about functional
programming
with java so when i first saw functional
programming i was like
you know what is this i saw functions by
function
predicates being used all over the place
and to be honest i only realized the
power of it when i learned about
declarative programming so you see most
of us write
imperative programming which means that
you define every single
implementation detail of your code
whereas declarative
simply tell it what you want instead of
defining
you know the details for example you
might have a variable
or actually you might have a loop right
so you define
you know the initial value how to
increment it and how to stop it right
so with declarative programming you have
none of that you simply
tell it what you want and that's what
i'm going to teach you in this course
so in this course i'm going to teach you
exactly you know what the differences
what the differences are between
imperative and declarative programming
and why you want to move away from
imperative programming
then i'm going to teach you about the
functional interfaces that java has to
provide
so functions buy functions predicates
consumers suppliers
and all that good stuff right so once
you learn that
you can then start to use streams and
optionals
to write code in a declarative way and
then towards the end i'm going to teach
you one of my favorite design
patterns when it comes to functional
programming and that is the
combinator design pattern which is
really really awesome
it's really good for validation where
you simply define
all of your validations in an interface
and then you define exactly
step by step what you want your
validation to be
it's really really awesome and finally
i'm also going to teach you exactly
about
lambdas callbacks and the properties of
functional programming
so that you fully grasp exactly the
whole
concept so if you haven't subscribed to
my youtube channel
go ahead and subscribe because that way
i can you know provide
more awesome content like this without
further ado
let's go ahead and learn everything you
need to know about
functional programming with java
all right so before you start this
course i want to make sure that you
really
uh learn from this course because i want
to add value
so what i want from you is to go ahead
and practice as i teach because that's
the best way for you to learn
any new technology also go ahead and
join the
private facebook group so if you have
any questions you can go ahead and
engage
with other students and the group is
full of cool people
just like you so this is all i wanted to
say for now
and enough of me talking let's go ahead
and
learn about functional programming
all right let's go ahead and bootstrap
our application
where i'm going to show you all the
examples throughout
this course so i've got intellij
right here and if you've never used
intellij
then i highly suggest you to enroll to
my
free course where i teach you pretty
much how to use
this awesome ide and to be honest
as a software engineer this is probably
the ide
of your choice when it comes to java
back-end development
so let me go back to intellij and
the first thing i want to do is to
create a project
and right here i'm going to pick maven
now
the project sdk it doesn't really matter
whether you use
java 11 12 or any other version as long
as
is above 1.7
so i'm going to stick with 11 right here
and as i said
the version does not matter next let me
go ahead and click
next and then right here for the group
id i'm going to say
com dot and then amigos
and then code so right here this could
be your own organization
and right here let me simply name this
as
java and then functional
and then i'm going to press next and
then i'm going to save this under code
and then java
functional and then simply press finish
there we go let me actually collapse
this maven tab right here
and also let me collapse this
and right here go ahead and simply
enable auto import to import
dependencies and this is the actual pom
file right so if i open the functional
oh actually
java functional folder inside you see
that we have only the pump file
and this contains the group id artifact
id
and then the actual version so let me
just remove that line
and also remove this pop-up and finally
i'm going to put this
full screen and this
is all and actually let me just close
this because we're not going to need
this pom file and this is pretty much
everything you need in order to
bootstrap the application to follow
along
so obviously i'm going to give you the
source code at the end
of this course but i highly suggest you
to practice as
i teach because that's the best way of
you
learning any new topic this is all for
now
if you have any questions about intellij
as i said
go ahead and roll to my course right
here where i teach you
everything you should be aware of this
awesome ide
let me go ahead and give you an example
of imperative programming
so imperative programming involves
you as a developer defining every single
detail about your implementation
so right here inside of the source
folder
inside of main and in java
let's go ahead and create a new package
so you can right click on
this folder or i'm going to use keyboard
shortcuts and also you can see
down here so right here you can see all
the keyboard shortcuts that i'm going to
use
throughout this course so right here i'm
going to use
the error so i'm going to select package
and then right here i'm going to name
this as imperative
and then ok now inside go ahead and
create class
and this will be called as main
now let me collapse this and inside i'm
going to type
p s and then vm
for public static main there we go
and now we have a main method that we
can
run so let's go ahead and define a list
and the type of this list will be of
type
and then person so right here let me go
ahead and simply name this as
people equals to and then
list and then dot and then off
so right here what we're gonna do is
simply create few people or actually
a few people of time person so right
here let's go ahead and simply
create a class so uh let's go ahead and
say static
and then class and then person
and this person will have a name so
private
and then final string
and a name and we also
will define a gender so
enum and this will be gender
and the gender will be male or female
and then right here what we're going to
do well actually
underneath is simply say private
final and then gender
and that will be the gender and let me
add this to constructor
and there we go so now we have
this class right here called person
and let me also define a two string
method right here so two
and then string and there we go
so now right here we can simply say
list of and then new
and then person and right here let's
give it a name
so john and john
is a male and let me have a static
import for this
and let's go ahead and duplicate this so
i'm going to press command d a couple of
times
and there we go so let's have maria
and she's a female let's have
aisha she's also a female
just like that let's have
alex it's a male and let's finally have
alice just like that and alice she's
of course a female
so now that we have this
list right here let's go ahead and find
out
how many females that we have so
the way that we will do it with uh
the imperative approach is let me add a
comment right here so in
an imperative approach is simply
by doing the following so first we need
an empty list
and then of type and then person
and then let me simply say females right
here
equals to a list of
and then oh actually not even list of
let's go ahead and say new
and then array list so this is an empty
list
now what we need to do is to loop
through people
so let's go ahead and simply say four
and then person and then person
inside of people
and right here we're going to say if
and then person or actually let me go
and simply say
female and then dot
equals to person dot
and then gender just like that so if
this
is the case i'm going to say females
don't
and then add and then person
just like that and that with semicolon
and then right here at the very
end what i'm going to do is simply print
each people
so again let me simply copy this
just like that and then right here
this instead of people
this will be females females and this
will also be
female and then south
just like that so system.out.printline
oops just like that and then
female now if i go ahead and pretty much
run this class right here so let's go
ahead and run
this class can
and there we go so right here you can
see
that we have only females
in our output and basically this
is pretty much what imperative
programming is
so basically we are defining every
single
detail so right here you can see that
first we have
an empty list and then we loop through
that
and then we have an if statement and
finally we have a final for loop
looping through females and you can see
that there is a lot of logic
not you know you know a substantial
amount of logic but you can see that for
example
this if statement is some logic and
also you can see that this is a lot of
code
for something very simple and this is
what i wanted to show you about the
imperative approach
next let's go ahead and implement this
using
the declarative approach and you will
see
that it's much neater and
we pretty much just tell it what we want
to do
instead of defining every single
implementation
detail right here
so to use declarative approach with java
ia functional style programming we
simply have to do the following let me
let me collapse this so right here so
what we're going to do
here is instead of us
creating a list and then having two for
loops what i'm going to do is the
following
first let me go ahead and pretty much
have a comment
and right here this will be declare
relative and then approach now
the way that we use declarative approach
is by using streams
with collections so don't worry about
um so much about what a stream
is because i'm going to show you exactly
later on
but for now just follow along so go
ahead and simply
say people so people is the original
list right here so this list of people
and then dot and then stream
right here so now we have a stream
and a stream allows us to go into an
abstract
mode where we simply tell it what we
want
so right here let's go ahead and simply
say dot and then
filter and what we want to filter
is basically this so right here we have
a person
so this takes a person and then i'm
going to say the exact same thing right
here so i'm going to take
this if statement oops
let me press command w a couple of times
command c
and then put it here there we go so you
can see that
i'm filtering and then this takes a
person
and i'm using this same if statement so
basically
female.equals and then person.gender
right and then finally i'm going to say
don't and then collect and then
collectors
and then to list end up with semicolon
and right here what i'm going to do is
put this on a new line and the same
with collect just like that
and right here we can simply now go
ahead and simply say
dot and then for each
and then we can use system
dot and then out and then column column
and then print line
so now let me actually add um
right here so let me simply add this as
a
south so i'm going to print this
just like that there we go
and let me do the same here so i'm going
to copy that
and then paste that take this comment
put it here so you can see exactly in
the console what i'm doing
so now you can see that
this is much concise
and right here you can see that i'm not
creating a list
and then adding to that list and then
doing the if statement so on and so
forth so you can see that
is very straightforward and i'm just
telling what i want
so from the people array
list or a list basically this is a list
i'm going to stream so i'm going to go
into this abstract mode
then i'm going to filter all the females
and then i'm going to collect to a list
and finally i'm going to print
everything
so technically i don't even need this
collector list
because i'm simply printing out things
so let me simply run this for now so you
can see exactly
what's happening there we go so
basically you can see
that we have the exact same output
right so if i put this whole screen you
can see that we have the exact same
output
but the declarative approach is much
neater so obviously if you were to have
this into a list right here so this is
where
collect comes into play and then i can
remove
this line and this with semicolon
and then extract this to a variable and
then say
females
and then two right and you can see that
now
i've got a list right here and i could
again
simply say females to dot
and then for rich system dot out
column column print line
so if i run again
you can see that this is the exact same
output
so there we go now you should have a
full understanding of the differences
between
declarative and imperative
approach so obviously i've just shown
you
uh you know the difference between both
but there are a few things that we need
to understand
in order to write code
like this right so i'm going to teach
you
about functions by functions predicates
by predicates consumers
and you know all the good stuff that
java
has to offer when it comes to functional
programming
if you have any questions go ahead and
drop me a message otherwise
let's move on
all right let's go ahead in this section
learn about the
java.util.function package
so basically this package contains
functional interfaces that provides
target times for lambda expressions and
method
references so each functional interface
has a single abstract method
basically you could have one interface
with multiple default methods
but you must have only one single
abstract method to be considered as a
functional interface so basically you
can see
some examples right here so the
assignment the assignment context so
this is how you for example
define a predicate and this is how for
example you
use it within the actual uh
you know stream so right here you've
seen that we can get stream
from a list right so streaming and
filter
and there's another example where you
can do some casting
so this package right here contains a
bunch
of functional interfaces right here you
can see
by consumer by function binary operator
by predicate boolean supplier consumer
and the list goes on so they are pretty
much
identical apart from the type so the
ones that
you will most likely be using are
functions
by functions predicates by predicates
and consumers and also there is a by
consumer
but i'm like but i'm going to explain
exactly how everything fits together
because once you learn those main ones
then the rest will be very simple
so right here i want to show you that so
we have a predicate so where is the
predicate
so let me find predicate so right here
so
a predicate let me quickly show you a
predicate
and show you that we actually have used
uh you know a predicate before so a
predicate represents
uh a predicate basically this particular
represents a predicate a boolean value
function of one argument
so let me go back to intellij and
right here remember where we had this
declarative approach
so right here so this filter so
basically if i
pretty much extract this into a variable
you can see that this is a predicate
and look at this this predicate
looks like this so the predicate
accepts a person and then
returns true or false based
of that person i.e whether the person
is of type female
right but what we've done right here we
simply inlined
like that that's why you don't see the
predicate
keyword but indeed this is
a predicate and a predicate looks
like this so
don't worry about this if it doesn't
make sense
but i'm going to try my best to explain
you exactly
how you go from uh you know normal
java functions to the functional
interface world join me in the next one
all right so i've gone ahead and created
a new package right here called
functional interface and inside
of this package i'm going to go ahead
and create a class
and first i'm going to name this class
as underscore and then function
and i'm going to explain why i'm saying
underscore right here but for now go
ahead and simply say
underscore and fun underscore function
or you can name
this anything other than
function without underscore right so
right here what i'm going to do is
simply say public static void
main to have a main method
and right here what i'm going to do is
simply do
the following so let's go ahead and
create a function
so static and then function so this
function
will take a number right so take a
number
and then increment that number by one
so let's go ahead and simply say int
and then increment
and then this will take an integer
number and then it will return
number and then plus one
so now if i go ahead and simply say
increment
and then zero
and then end up with semicolon and
if i pretty much extract this to a
variable and for now let's go ahead and
simply sound
this increment and
let me put this full screen let me run
this
now oops
i'm running the wrong one so i need to
run this function
there we go so you can see that the
result is one very simple
so if i put one right here this
will be two so what i want to show you
is how we go from this
so this is what you are used to
to this right here so let's go ahead and
learn about the
function um
interface so where is the function
so this one right here so
this says that represents a function
that take
that accepts one argument and then
produces
a result so this is pretty much
what we have here right so this function
that we have so this is a
normal function in java so this is what
you are
used to so this takes
an input and then returns
one single output right here and this
is pretty much the equivalent right here
so represents a function that accepts
one argument
and produces a result so the way that we
convert this into a function
right here is the following
so let's go ahead and simply
say function
and if i actually delete this so i want
to show you something so function
you can see that this function takes
a t right so t and then r so basically
these are the data types of the input
and the output so let's go ahead right
here
and simply say that this will be of type
integer so the input is integer
and the output is also an integer
right here so now let me go ahead and
simply say
increment and then function
will actually increment by and then
one function right here
and then this will be equal
to right now this is where things
become a bit tricky so here equals two
and then this will be the actual number
and then right here we pass a lambda and
then i'm going to say
number and then plus plus
there we go and that would semi column
so you can see that
this and this are the exact same
thing so basically this integer right
here
corresponds to the actual input so
this one right here right this data type
this integer corresponds to the return
type and then this number
corresponds to the parameter to
this function right here and then i'm
saying
number plus plus well actually let me
simply make them the same so
number plus one and
let me also rename this function to
increment
by and then one so
you can see that this is pretty much the
same
but now we are talking in
functional style world
so now the way that we use this
is as follows so go ahead and simply say
increment by one and the reason why
we're not
seeing this this function is because we
can actually put it inside of this
method
so inside of this main method we can
paste that function there
or if you want this can also be static
like that right so let me actually
um put this on a new line so you see
exactly
how it is so right here i can say
increment
by one function and what i'm going to do
is simply say
dot and then apply
so the apply pretty much takes the
actual argument so let me go ahead and
simply say 1
and then right here i'm going to say
increment and then 2
and i can change this data type to
integer
and then simply say south and then
increment 2
and then let me simply run this again
you can see that we have the exact same
output
so this is how you use a
function so basically it's the exact
same thing
as this function right here but in a
functional style way so if you have any
questions
about this go ahead and drop me a
message but i'm going to show you
exactly
how all of this fits together right
because now
you might be asking you know why should
i use
you know this function right here
instead of
a normal regular function right
and don't worry by the end of this
course everything will be
clarified so there are a few methods
that i want to teach you so
right here if i pretty much say
increment function uh or actually
increment by one function
dot you can see that we have um apply
and then this method right here and then
so i want to teach you what this method
is because you might use it later on
so let me simply move that and this is
all for now
join me in the next video see ya
all right let's say that you want to
combine
multiple functions together to achieve
a desired state or a desired output
so let's say that you have this function
right here so
increment by one function but let's also
create
another function oh actually let me not
copy base but simply say
static and then function
and this function will take an integer
and this function will also return an
integer
and then i'm going to say multiply
by and then 10
right here so this will take the number
oops number and then this will be
lambda just like that and then number
times and then 10 just like that
so we have this function right here
and what we want to do is after
incrementing
so after incrementing uh
by one right here we want to apply
that other function immediately so you
could do
something like this so you could say int
increment will actually multiply
and then equals 2 and then multiply
by 10 let me actually rename this to a
function
just like that and then right here
you could say equals to
multiply by 10 function dot
apply and then increment
nn2 right
so this is
not quite right because
this is a name so right there and then
remove that
and this should be multiply by 10
let me grab that name there paste it
there and there we go
so now if i do a south and then multiply
by 10
function well actually
i'm getting all confused right here so
this should be multiply
there we go so this is the actual output
so now if i run
this you can see
that we take 2 multiplied by 10
is 20. so obviously
this is you know quite normal for us to
do
but we can do something better so what
we can do
is simply combine the two
functions together so right here what
i'm going to do
is simply say increment by one
function dot
and then and then multiply
by 10 function and
right here what i'm going to do is
simply
extract this to a variable so this will
give us
yet another function and let me simply
say
add by one
and then multiply
by 10 there we go
so if i put this on a new line and you
can see exactly what it's doing
so now let's go ahead and simply say add
by 1 and multiply by 10
and then simply say apply and you can
see that you can
keep on you know chaining these
functions
as you go along but for now let's simply
chain two functions
so now i'm gonna say apply and the
number that i want
is one right
so this should give us the exact same
result
so 1 plus 1 2 2 plus
10 you guessed it right that will be 20.
so obviously i need to
put this around system.out.printline
just like that run this again
you can see that we have 20 right here
so if i change
this to let's change this number
right here so instead of one let's go
ahead and change it to
four four plus one five
times ten fifty right here
and this is pretty much how you chain
functions together
so if you have any questions go ahead
and drop me a message
next let me go ahead and teach you about
by functions
all right so what a by function is
is the same as a function
but instead of taking one
input it takes two inputs and produces
one output ends by function
for two things right
so right here we have
this function right here so this one add
by one and multiply by 10.
so let's say that the first number that
we give it
is the one that it should increment and
then the second one is the one that it
should
multiply by so right here
let me go ahead and define this as a
normal function so you can see exactly
um the equivalent so
increment and will actually increment
by 1 and
multiply just like that so now right
here
we have a second argument so
int num to multiply
by just like that
and now i'm going to wrap everything
within parenthesis and then say
times and then num to multiply by
now the way that we define the exact
same thing
but using a by function
is as follow so let's go ahead and
simply say buy
and then function so the first
argument is the first
input which is the actual number that we
want to
add one by so let me go ahead and simply
say
this is an integer
the second one is also an integer
and the third one is also an integer
so bear in mind that you can have
different data types depending
of your circumstances so right here let
me simply
say that this will have the same name
but
by function so usually you wouldn't
include the pi function for the name but
i'm just doing it so that you
understand exactly and reason about
these things so right here this now
will take two things so because it takes
two arguments we need to wrap this
within
parenthesis so this will be number
to increment
by one and then
number two
mul t ply and then buy
and this will be now a lambda
and what we do is simply say number two
increment by one plus and then one
right so this is the exact same thing
that we did here
and then this will be within parenthesis
and then finally times
and a number to multiply by
and that would semicolon and let me just
put
this on a new line yet again
so you see exactly everything so i've
got bigger font because i want you to
see exactly properly
but you know you shouldn't indent things
like this
but basically this right here
is the exact same thing as this
so now let's go ahead and use it so
right here
remember we had this function so
add by 1 and then multiply by 10.
so let's go ahead and say this now is a
by
function and this was the function
example
so let me actually add a comment so
takes
one argument
and produces one
result so now the
by function is almost the same
but it takes two arguments right here
so let's go ahead and use our function
so right here
so increment by one and then multiply
let's go ahead and give it four
and then let's multiply four
by one hundred so basically this will be
four plus one five 5 x 100
500 so let's go ahead and simply
uh i'm not going to even put this into a
variable
i'm simply going to say south and then
just like that so let me
put like that and there we go
so now if i run this
you can see that we have 500 right here
now let me go ahead and use the by
function
so if i escape out of this
and let's actually have the same system
right here
so system.line and right here
let me simply use the actual function
i think we have to have it as static so
this
guy right here so this has to be static
there we go now it should appear by
function
and this should be dot and then apply
and apply takes 4 and 100
now if i run this
you can see that we have the exact same
result
so this one right here is using
normal java function and this one right
here
is using the buy function let me go
ahead and show you
the actual docks you'll see that we have
lots of buy so let me say let me search
for
buy so you could see that we have you
know
a double by function to int by function
to long by function and all of these by
functions
are the exact same thing as the function
but they take two arguments as you can
see
here right so the same with predicate so
it takes two arguments
and returns true or false so this
is the difference between a function and
a byte function
if you have any questions go ahead and
join me message
otherwise let's move on
all right next let's go ahead and learn
about consumer
so a consumer so let me search for
consumer
right here so consumer so a consumer
represents an operation that accepts a
single input argument and returns no
result so let me show you exactly
first the non-functional way and then
the functional way
so let's say that right here again let's
have public static
void main and right here let's go ahead
and define
a static class and then
customer and then let's go ahead and
simply say private
final and let me put this full screen so
private final
and then string and then customer
name private final
string customer
phone number just like that
so next let me add that to constructor
and now what i'm gonna do
is have a function right here so let me
go and simply say static
and then right here let's go ahead and
say greet
and then customer so this will take
a customer
and right here let's go ahead and simply
say
south and then hello
and then customer and then dot customer
name
and then right here plus and comment
thanks for registering
and then phone number
and then plus customer
dot and then customer phone number
so let me actually put this on a new
line so you can see
everything so now let's go ahead and
simply create a new customer so new
customer this will be let's say that
maria
and then my real phone number will be
99999
right so let me go ahead and cut
this and then simply say create customer
pass new customer just like that and end
up with semicolon
just like that so now
if i run this class
you can see that we have hello maria
thanks for registering phone number
99999 so the way that we achieve the
same
but using the functional interface
so the consumer functional interface
is by doing the following so let me go
ahead and simply say static
and then consumer
so consumer takes one argument so this
will be of type
customer and then right here let me go
ahead and simply say
great customer consumer
equals to and then we'll take the
customer and
what we're going to do is pretty much
the exact same thing right here
so let me grab all of this and then
paste it there
and basically now i can go ahead and
simply say
greet customer consumer
dot and then right here instead of apply
we simply accept now let me go ahead and
extract
this customer so maria
and then also pass maria right here
so there we go so this is using
functional interface
so this is actually consumer
and then normal java
function right so
if i run this
you can see that we have the exact same
thing right
so basically a consumer takes one
argument
and pretty much returns nothing it's
like a
void function right so this customer
right here
is the data type of the input so is
this one this customer
is the actual name of the uh input so
this customer
right here and void you could
technically say that void
is a consumer so if you have any
questions on this
go ahead and drop me a message otherwise
let's learn about
by consumers
all right so let's go ahead and learn
about the by consumer
so the same way that we've done with
functions
and by functions we have the same
for consumer so pretty much every one of
these
uh functional interfaces they have the
buy
version so in front of it they have the
buy
version so the by
simply means that instead of taking one
argument it takes two arguments
now let's go ahead and change this
function so let me simply
grab that and
let's go ahead and simply say v2 for
example so this will be the version 2.
so what we're going to have is a by
consumer
right here and
let me import this so first we will take
the customer and then we will
have the boolean so right here so this
boolean
so this boolean will represent
whether we should hide the customer's
phone number
show and then phone
and then number so now we have an error
because we have two arguments
and because we have two arguments we
need to enclose these
within parenthesis just like that
now right here what i'm going to do is
instead of
printing the actual phone number like
that i'm
going to say the following so i'm going
to put this within parentheses
just like that and
right here i'm going to say show phone
number so if show phone number
then we can pretty much print that
otherwise i'm simply going to have
some stars just like that
so now let's go ahead and test this out
so let's go ahead and simply say great
customer v2
and let's pass maria and then right here
let's simply say true for now
so this is actually complaining because
we need to say dot
accept and if i run this
you can see that this is the
version two of our function
now let's go ahead and simply say false
run that and you can see that now we are
hiding the
number right here so basically if you
were to
convert this into a normal regular java
function
this would be as follow so let me just
duplicate all of this just like that
call this v2 and then right here
we simply take the exact same variable
so show phone number
but right here boolean show phone number
and let me grab everything from here
and then put it here
there we go and i would semicolon
and i can simply
now go ahead and say get oh actually
great customer v2
pass maria and then true
run there we go and you can see that we
have the exact same information
so there we go this is how you use a
by consumer if you have any questions go
ahead and drop me a message
otherwise let's move on
all right let's go ahead and learn about
predicates so i've gone ahead
inside of the functional interface
package created
this underscore predicate class
and inside let's go ahead and simply
type public static
void main and let's go ahead and learn
about predicates
so let's say that you want to
do the following so let's say that you
have
a function so a normal travel function
so static
and then this will return a boolean
and right here let's simply go ahead and
say
is phone number valid
so let's go ahead and simply take a
phone number so string
and then phone number
and for now let's go ahead and keep it
very simple
but this validation is not real but
it's just to illustrate the actual
example and purpose
of predicates so right here let's simply
say that
this note this phone number in order to
be valid it has to meet the following
criterias
so let's return phone number
dot and then starts
with and let's say that
the phone number has to start with zero
seven
and let's also say that the phone number
and
phone number dot and then length
is equal to eleven
so this is a simple phone validation
uh method but this is not real it's just
to illustrate the purpose
now let's go ahead and simply do a south
here and let's go ahead and have this
phone number
so zero seven and then zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero
zero and let's have another one
zero and then nine and then we can add
um you know a couple digits
like so right so the validation is not
real
but this will illustrate the purpose so
now if i run
this so let me run this main method
you can see that i'm printing the number
but what i meant to do was to actually
let me cut this so what i meant to print
was is phone number valid and then pass
the actual phone number so
same with that one cut it
is phone number valid and then paste it
run it again you can see that the first
phone number is valid so it meets
the actual criterias let's also have
another one
so the same but this will be 10
characters long and if i run
this again you can see that the first
one is valid
the second one the second one the second
one isn't and the third one
isn't as well so right here we're simply
doing a simple phone validation
uh check now in order for us to use
the functional style we can use the
predicate so predicate right here so you
can see
represents a boolean valid function of
one argument right so
right here the way that we use a
predicate is as follows
so this exact same function as predicate
will be something like this static
and then right here predicate
and then this will take a string so this
will be the phone number
and then let's copy this exact same name
and then let's simply say predicate
and right here this will be equal to
and then phone number
so let's actually grab this
and then this lambda
and on a new line i'm simply going to
grab this
and then paste it and then end with
semicolon
now let's go ahead and use it so to use
it
is phone number valid predicate
dot and then test so this is the actual
method that we need to use
so now we're going to test the following
let's test the first number
so we know that the first number is
valid so basically this will be the
exact same thing so
we need to simply south this
just like that there we go
and let me duplicate this and basically
we should have the exact same output
there we go and then paste that in
let me do south
without predicate
and then right here weight
predicate
and if i run this
you can see that we have the exact same
result so
true false false and without predicate
true false false so basically
this is the equivalent so the predicate
is the equivalent
as this normal java function
and the cool thing about predicates is
that you can have
a bunch of predicates and then combine
them together
so the same way that we've done with
function using and then
we can we can also use it with
predicates
so let's say that we have another
predicate
so let's have another project so static
and then predicate
and this predicate will take a string
and then let's say contains
and then number and then let's simply
say number three
so if the phone number contains number
three so phone number
and right here i'm simply gonna say
phone number
dot and then contains and then three
just like that now the way that
you chain predicates is
as follow so right here let's simply go
ahead and say
is phone number valid so we're gonna
pass
this phone number so this one right here
there we go
and then we can say dot and then is
phone number valid predicate dot
and then and another predicate so the
other predicate
is contains number three
dot and then test let's actually pass
this number right here so the last one
there we go and let's wrap everything
without a system.print line
let me put this on a new line and
just like this there we go
so if i say right here is
phone number valid and
contains number three
equals and then plus the actual
result let's do the same for a different
number
so let's actually let's actually do for
this one very first one
so right here and
let's actually put a three right here
so this should be false because the
phone number
isn't valid but it contains number three
right here
but this one the phone number is valid
so it starts with zero seven
eleven characters long and contains
number three
at the end so let's go ahead and
run this method and there we go so you
can see that
the second one is true as i explained
why
and the first one is false now
you can use ands but you can also use
or so or means either one of them is
true so if i was to say right here so
instead of and i can use or
right and then if i remove
three here and put a zero run this
this will still be true is true
because we only need one condition to be
true
if you use an and so if you chain
multiple predicates together
using an and all of them have to be true
so the same way that we have predicates
we have by predicates by and then
predicates right here and basically they
are the same thing
but instead of taking one argument they
take
two arguments so i'm not gonna give you
a full example on by predicates because
you should be familiar now with
by predicates by functions by consumers
so on and so forth
so if you have any questions on
predicates
go ahead and drop me a message otherwise
let's go ahead and learn about the final
functional interface i want to show you
and then we can start putting all the
puzzle together
so that all of this starts to make sense
and how you actually end up using it
join me in the next one see ya
all right go ahead and inside of the
functional interface package create a
class called
underscore supplier with a public static
void
main method so let's go ahead and learn
about
what a supplier is so if i go to the
docs
right here you can see that they say
supplier t
represents a supplier of results
so basically sometimes you might have a
method right here
that simply uh let's say that
we have a method uh like that so like
a method like this so static and then
get
or actually string
get connection
url watch let's simply say get db
connection url right so
this will take no arguments
and let's simply return
and then for example j dbc
column for slash forward slash localhost
and then 5432 forward slash
let's say uh users right
so this is not real but you get the idea
so the way that we can
use this function now is if i simply say
south
and then get db connection url
and then if i run this you can see that
we get the actual connection url for
some kind of database so the purpose of
this function right here is simply to
return
a value right here so this is the value
that it returns
so we can do so we can use a supplier to
represent the exact same thing so i'm
going to copy
this url and to
have this java function as functional
we simply have to say supplier or
actually static
and then supplier and then this
will supply a string and then get
let's grab this
and then supplier and
right here equals two and then
what we need to do is simply have
parenthesis
and then we simply pass or actually
return this
just like that so if i put this on a new
line
so you can see exactly what i'm doing
and you can see that
now this is the exact same thing but if
i go ahead and simply say
system.out.println so south
and then right here to use this i can
say get
db connection url supplier dot
and then get so now if i
run this i do
get the exact same result
so this is pretty much how you use a
supplier so a supplier simply
returns any kind of value that you want
right
so this data type doesn't have to be a
string
it could be you know your custom classes
your custom objects
um you know an array pretty much
anything that you want so for example if
you wanted to return a list right here
you could simply say list and then of
type
and then string right here and then here
i would say
list dot of
and then just like that and that would
semicolon
right so now if i run this
you can see that this now is a list so
if i was to return something else so
right here let me simply add
comma new line and then this
like so so it's much neater
just like that oops just like that
and right here let's simply say uh
customer for example
right so get a connection urls
and then supplier and then here urls
run this and there you go so now we are
returning
a list with two urls so
if you have any questions on suppliers
go ahead and drop a message otherwise
let's move on
all right so by now you should see
exactly the differences between
writing a normal java function and
functional interfaces so the benefit
of you know knowing the functional
interfaces
is when you start to use optionals and
streams but more specific streams right
so once you start using streams with all
of these functional interfaces
you will start to write clean code and
that's what i'm going to teach you
next
okie dokie now that you've learned about
consumers
functions by functions predicates by
predicates
and suppliers and also i think by
consumers
now let's go ahead and actually learn
how this is useful
to us when writing code so
go ahead and create a new package under
java
so package and call this as
streams now go ahead and create
a new class and simply call it
underscore and then
stream just like that
enter public static void
main enter now
remember inside of the imperative uh
package go ahead and open that up and
let's actually steal some code
so right here let's steal all of this so
the enum gender as well as the
person class so let me close this
and then right here let me paste that in
and i'm gonna cancel because i don't
want to import from imperative.main
so cancel and
let me go back again and let's actually
steal
some code again so let's take this
list right here so we're going to take
this list and then we can close this
once more
and then right here inside let's go
ahead
and paste it and you see right here is
trying to import from imperative.main
cancel out of it and let's simply import
the actual list
ourselves so i'll just press option
enter
and right here let's import mail and
gender
just like that and finally let's go
ahead and add a static import for those
so i'm just pressing option and then
enter
add static import now let me go ahead
and close
this and let's actually
use what we've learned in the previous
section
with streams so this is pretty much
where
everything starts to make sense so
let's go ahead and use a couple of those
functional interfaces that we've learned
so if i collapse this or actually open
this
so consumer function predicate and
suppliers
so go ahead and simply say people
dot and then stream
right so stream pretty much
takes us to an abstraction mode
and if you want to learn about all of
this
i've got this course right here where i
teach
everything about the java streams api
because once you've because once you
learn this
the way that you write your java code
will change quite significantly
so stuff that you use to take 20 lines
of code you can simply collapse into
perhaps
five lines of code and to be honest
knowing how to use
the java streams api will make you a
much
better developer so i also have a
free video on youtube where i teach
about
filter soar group by all match basically
this is a
an introduction of this awesome api
but for now let's go ahead and learn
some of these methods
so go ahead and say people.stream
and now go ahead and simply say dot
so what i want you to do is to actually
look
carefully so right here so look at the
methods that we have
we have map collect filter
find first for reach all match
but what i want you to see is exactly
look the map function
takes a function right takes a function
of some type that extends person
and then you can see the other one so
the other
argument so question mark extends our
mapper
so this is exactly what we've learned
right so a function takes an input and
produces an output so the same with
collect
so collect is a supplier and you can see
you buy consumer so this is awesome
right this is everything that we've
learned
so the same with filter takes a
predicate find
first so this returns simply an optional
for which takes a consumer right
let's look another one so for example
drop
wow this takes a predicate find any
flat map so this is a very useful
function
takes a function inside and right here
flat map to wind map to double so this
takes a two double function
right and you can see right here
non match a variable you of a very
useful function as well
reduce binary operator
and then right here you have another
reduce
and then look at this sorted takes a
comparator it's not relevant to us
take wow you can see that this takes a
predicate
and to array into function basically
this
is pretty much everything that we have
learned
right so functions by function consumers
predicates
and the other good stuff so basically
this is now
where everything comes into
action so let me go ahead and show you
for example how to use
this map function so go ahead and simply
select the map function and the map and
the map and and the map function
simply does transformations so right
here
this takes a person right
and from here what we want to return so
i want to return
person dot and then the actual gender
now let's go ahead and simply say dot
and then collect
and then collect this to set right
so and also um let me
extract this to a variable
genders and then south
and then genders or actually
not even south so let me let me simply
remove that
because i want you to see exactly what
we're doing so right here
so instead of collect let's go ahead and
simply say dot
and then look at this for each
takes a consumer and we've learned about
consumers
right a consumer simply takes
an argument and produces nothing so void
right so right here we will take a
gender
and what we want to do with this gender
so we want to simply
do a system dot
out dot print line and then
gender and now we can use method
reference with this
like so and beautiful code now
let me go ahead and run this method
so you can see what we are doing
tada there we go male and female right
so you can see that we mapped everything
so right here we stream the
people list so
oops so right here we stream
the people list right contains a bunch
of people
right here so john maria aisha alex and
alice
so we map so we perform a transformation
on that list so we convert
every single one of them into a gender
so now we simply have
a list full of genders and then we
collect
to a set removing duplicates
and then we simply print that's why you
see that we have
only male and female right here
so if i was to have another gender right
here
cannot or actually
prefer
not to
say but basically this is not gender i'm
just giving you an example
so right here let's add another one
another person
right here there we go
then prefer not to say this will be
bob and you could tell that this is a
gender but
so if i run this you can see that now we
have
prefer not to say as well right here
so if i was to now map this
into the actual name right so let's
say name and then run this
we simply now get the actual names
instead of
genders so this is really
really really awesome so let me actually
let me also show you that we can simply
get the length of each name so
let's also perform another map operation
right or in or in this scenario let's
say
map to int this takes the
actual uh name so this time it's name
and then simply say name dot and then
length
and right here we're not going to
collect set so let me delete that
and then we can even change this to
method reference
just like that if i run this
you can see now the length of each name
so
this is the power of streams
so you might be asking you know what is
this
right or what is this or what is this
so let me just show you right now so
what i'm going to do
here is simply extract this to a
variable
and also this to a variable
and also this to a variable
and now check this out so this is what
you've been learning
in the past videos so look at this
function
that takes a person returns a string
and then the same here two in function
we haven't learned to int function but
basically this is the same thing
so this takes a string and returns
an integer that's all it does and you
can see right here
in consumer so an end consumer
simply takes an integer and it prints
out the result so right here
so let me actually replace this with a
lambda so you can see exactly what is
this
you see that this is what we've been
learning throughout this course but when
you use it with streams
you don't have to have all of this
syntax basically you can ditch the left
hand side
and just keep these right so if i now
inline everything so command
shift n command shift and there
command shift and there and look at this
right and here even method reference
and there we go so if you want to learn
more about streams
go ahead and check my course on java
streams api
where you learn everything about
writing code in a declarative way
this is all for now join me in the next
one
all right let me show you some other
methods right here so still
right here so let's go ahead and
for now i'm going to pretty much just
comment everything right here
so i'm going to comment this and right
here let's go ahead and simply say
people
dot and then stream and then right here
let's go ahead and simply say
all and then match basically we want to
know
that in our list we only have females
so right here so this takes a predicate
and remember a predicate looks like this
so this will take a person
and then in this list we want to make
sure that we
only have females so
female dot and then equals
person dot and then
why should not people person dot
and then gender there we go
and now and i'll end this with semicolon
and if i extract this to a variable you
can see that this
is a boolean now let me go ahead and
simply say contains
only females there we go and if i do a
south on this
south and then contains only females
and let me actually go ahead and
destructure
all of this so i'm going to extract this
to a variable
and check this out so right here so
we've learned about
predicates right so this is what we've
learned previously
so now let me go ahead and run
this again
and you can see that it's false right
because in our list
so right here in our list we contain
both male and females
so if you want for example to say
um or is
say the opposite you could say for
example
i think match let's look at for let's
look at match so
any match right here right so any match
so any match means any match taking our
predicate
so if we have at least one female
then this will return to run this
there we go true right so if i
for example remove all the females here
just like that run it again
and it's false now right so
let me undo all of that and finally we
have
uh i think it's non match
right so let's say that now we change
this to
prefer not say and let's remove
bob from here so basically
i want to make sure that in our list we
do not have
someone with prefer not say gender
if i run this you can see it's true
if i add bob back
this will be false there we go
so you can see the power of streams
right
so obviously we have other methods
really really useful methods so if i do
uh
person or actually people dot and then
stream
dot and look at those methods
right so
mean peak reduce sorted
take wow um
so right here drop while
not much you've seen find first
map and map to int so basically once you
learn
all of this the way you write java code
will change and you will become a much
better java developer so this
is all for this video
next let me also show you that you can
use um you know
all of the goodness of java functional
interfaces
with optionals because you know again
optionals
changes the way that you deal with null
pointer exceptions in java join me in
the next one
see ya
all right let me go ahead and show you
how to use java optionals
with functional interfaces so if you've
never heard about java optionals or if
you've never
used java optionals go ahead and check
my youtube channel
where i've got this crash course on
java optionals and i highly
suggest you to learn how to use
optionals because
they will help you a lot in terms of
dealing with null pointer exceptions
so let me go back to intellij and let me
create a new package
so right here optionals
and inside let's go ahead and create
main class
and right here public static void main
and there we go so now let's go ahead
and simply say
optional dot and then
off nullable so right here let's simply
say
no right and
if i now press dot check this out
you can see that right here you have a
bunch of methods
but if you look closely again so these
methods
they do take for example the first one
or else to throw
takes a supplier right so this
supplies an exception you can see or
else or so right here this takes a
supplier
map again function if present consumer
filter
flat map so right here if present or
else
right is present or else
get so this is a supplier so let me
actually use
this one or else get and then
remember suppliers so right here
oops there we go so let me simply say
default value just like that
extract this to a variable and let me
simply name this as value
now if i go ahead and simply say south
on
value there we go if i run
this you can see that we get default
value
but now check this out if i simply add a
value here
so hello
run this again you can see that we get
a low right so let's
try something else so instead of or else
get
let's go ahead and simply say dot or
so right here so or else
throw so this again we have to
supply an exception oops just like that
new illegal set exception
and you can have for example a message
right there
and exception for example
right so you can see that if i extract
this to a variable
this is a supplier and we've learned
about suppliers remember
so right here so this is a supplier
right it takes no arguments but
it supplies a value so there we go
now let me again show you something else
so if i delete this
so instead of saying or else throw let's
go ahead and use
for example so let's use something that
has a consumer so
if present there we go if present we
receive the actual value
here and then we do something with
the value so right here let me simply
remove
that and let me move
this above and then this
there we go now because i only have
one single value but basically you could
do like some logic right here
right if you had like you know something
that you wanted to do like a business
logic right
so now because i only have one value
i can delete all of this i can delete
that and i can even go one step further
use lambda method reference just like
that and look at this
looks beautiful so now let me go ahead
and simply say
john gmail.com
in fact let's go ahead and pretty much
um have a custom message so right here
so email and what we're gonna do is
simply say
south
and then sending
email to and then
email there we go
now if i run this you can see
that right here we do get sending email
to
john but now as soon as i
pass a null here
right if i run this we get nothing
but now i can go ahead and pretty much
change this
with so there is another method right
here so
if present or else takes the consumer
and then the other empty action
is a runnable so that is our consumer so
let me actually
grab this so you can see what am i doing
so
this is the first one so this email
and then right here we have to pass
comma
right comma and then a runnable
so a runnable goes like that
and there we go so let me pretty much
just put this on a new line
and this on a new line just like that
and then if i close that indent things
there we go and then here what i'm going
to do is simply say south
cannot send email
there we go now if i run this
you see that we have cannot send email
as a default value
so again i can remove that and have
method reference and look at how this
now starts to flow guys
so this is the power of functional
programming
streams optionals and
you know once you start writing code
like this you can achieve
a lot more instead of using imperative
approach so as i said go ahead and roll
to
this course right here where i teach
everything you need to know about
java streams api also if you want to
learn about
optionals go ahead and check this video
where i show you
how to use optionals and how to be safe
with
no values this is all for
this section if you have any questions
go ahead and drop me a message
otherwise let's move on
let's go ahead and learn about this
awesome design pattern called
combinator so let me go ahead and first
create a new package
and right here i'm going to simply name
this as combinator
and then pattern so
right here what i want to do is to
create a
class so i want to create class and
let's say that we will start with the
user so the user actually a customer
so we have a customer and this customer
has
few properties so let me collapse this
so private final
string name let's also
give it an email phone number
and let's also give it a local date
for date of birth
now let me go ahead and pretty much just
add those to a constructor
and let me generate some getters right
here so get it
just like that so
now let's say that you have a system
right where customers do register to
your system
and you and you need to perform some
kind of validation
right so what you would do for example
would be something like this
so inside of your package you would
create a class
and then customer validator
and then service right
and in this class right here you would
have
few methods to validate few properties
of a customer
right so you could have a method so
right here you could say
public and then boolean
is email valid
right and this takes a customer or
better takes a string email
right and right here you'd simply say
return
and then email dot contains
you know this is a rubbish validation
but this is just for illustration
purposes
right so contains that
uh or actually contains the add symbol
for now let's keep it simple
then you might want to have order
validation for the actual
um phone number
so right here so is and then
phone number valid
so this will be phone number
and then right here phone number right
here contains
so instead of contains let's go ahead
and simply have a simple validation so
it starts with
and then plus and then zero
right and then what did we have so if i
go back so we have
uh date of birth so let's go ahead and
simply say that
the date of birth so right here
is adult so is adult
so right here we take a local
date and then d-o-b
and then what we're going to do here is
simply
say period dot and then between
so we're going to calculate the number
of years between
two dates so the start date will be
uh inclusive so this will be the dob so
customers
date of birth and then local date
dot and then now and then right here
dot and then get years and let's say
that for someone to be an adult they
have to be
over 16 just like that right so if i put
this full screen so you can see
so this is then your customer validator
service
right so now the way that you would use
it
is let's go ahead and create a new class
so
main and then public static void
main like that customer
and then customer equals to new and then
customer
and then right here let's go ahead and
simply say that this is alice
and then she has an email of alice
at gmail.com
and then the actual phone number is plus
and then zero so oops plus
and then zero and then any random number
and finally let's go ahead and simply
say that
she was born so local date
of and then 2000
just like that and then one
and then one and there we go so if i
collapse this
and you can see that now we have
a customer that we can perform some
validation
now obviously um you know this
um validator service right so this
could even be private so private
and then private and then right here so
let's go ahead and combine the both
let's go ahead and combine everything so
is
oh actually let's go ahead and simply
say public so this is the actual
uh interface that we provide to clients
so public
and then boolean and then
is valid
just like that and this now will take
a customer
and now what we're going to do is simply
say return
and then is email valid
customer dot get email
and then and and then
is phone number valid customer dot
get phone number and finally
and is in then adult customer
dot and then get and then dob
just like that so this is actually you
know
normal code uh but
so what i want to teach you really is
how we're going to be able to use
a functions to change this
in a much better way and a neater way
right so here if you have extra
validation you have to have another
method
like that and then simply append here
and then basically right here
you don't have visibility whether
um you know whether the phone number was
invalid or
it wasn't an adult or or anything right
because this simply returns a boolean
right is valid so if i go ahead and show
you what i mean so right here
let's go ahead and simply say customer
validated service
service equals to actually let me rename
this to
uh validation validate the service
new and then custom validate the service
now let's go ahead and say validated
service
dot is valid and then pass customer
there we go so what i'm going to do
actually is in line this
oops not that so basically i want to
inline
um this guy right here so like that
and then i'm going to do a south just
like that
and then end that like that so now if i
go ahead and run this
there we go so you can see that this
customer is valid
and from now on let's say that
we can
store customer
store customer in and then
db right so
now um actually let me say
if and then valid
right so now if i go ahead and pretty
much just for example remove the add
sign
run this you can see that now it's false
so it's not valid
and also let me go ahead and remove the
plus sign right here
there we go still not valid but now
you don't know exactly you know what is
wrong
with our validation so the combinator
pattern
it's an awesome design pattern that
allows you
to chain functions together so basically
a combinator
is a function that might take other
function as
arguments and returns new functions
so this is an awesome pattern that i'm
pretty sure
that you will love and that's what i'm
going to teach you
next
all right let's go ahead and use the
combinator pattern
to improve this validation service right
here that we have so validated service
actually
so this validation sub so so this class
right here
is okay but we can do
way better than this right because right
here for example
if you want to have um you know a
different method that validates for
example
just email and their phone number then
you would
duplicate this so right here and then
you would say
is valid phone number and email
and basically just remove for example is
adult from here
and we don't want to do this right so we
want to have a very
uh beautiful interface that we can
simply chain
all of these validations together so
let's go ahead
first and expand the project tab and
right here let's go ahead and simply
create
a class and this will be called
customer and then let's
actually name this as registration
valley data there we go
and instead of a class let's change it
to an interface
now what i'm going to do here is the
following so
right here i'm going to say that this
will extend
a function so remember we've used
functions right here
and the first argument that we want for
this interface is a customer
so the type of is a customer and then
right here let's go ahead and simply say
validation
and then result so
let me end that just like that
and let me put this on a new line so you
can see exactly what we're doing
now this validation result this will be
an enum so
enum and then validation
or let me actually just copy and paste
this so validation result just like that
and now i can import this oops
actually i did the right thing and let
me actually do a static import right
here
there we go now here what i'm going to
do is have
and you know few results that i want my
validated
service or actually my my customer
registration
validator to have so one i want this to
be
success right so this is where all the
validation is successful
then we have few errors so right here we
have
phone number
not and then valid
we also have email not and then
valid and we also have is
not an adult just like that
so the way that we're going to use this
with this interface is as follows so
this is where combinator pattern
kicks off so right here we're simply
going to have the
validations that we want right so here
you can have as many validations
as you want and then you chain them
together at the end
so right here let's go ahead and simply
say static
and then right here what we're going to
return is
this guy right here so the same
interface so right here we will return
this function right here right that
takes a customer
and returns a validation result so right
here i'm gonna say
is and then email valid and then i'm not
taking anything
there but right here what i want to say
is
return and then customer
and right here i'm going to say customer
so basically the exact same
validation that we had before so
customer dot
and then contains
and then at so if
this is the case what i'm going to do
is simply return you guessed it
success otherwise
phone number oh actually no phone number
email is not valid and let me have a
static import for this
and the same for success there we go
now let's go ahead and do the same for
phone number
right here let me actually steal some
code so from here
what did we have we had this
so i'm gonna copy that go back and then
is phone number
valid and then i'm going to
change that with this and then
customer dot get phone number
starts with that so if that is the case
then it's valid otherwise so right here
phone number is not valid let's go ahead
and do the same
for is adult so right here
static and then customer registration
validator is an
adult there we go let me steal some code
from here
so this is what i want
just like that go back and then
customer will actually return customer
and then i'm gonna paste that
and then right here customer
dot and then get dob
so if this is the case right so if the
customer
age is bigger than 16 what i'm gonna do
so let me put this on a new line so if
it's bigger than 16
what i'm gonna do is simply return
success
otherwise is not an adult
there we go indent this properly and
there we go so one final thing that now
we have to do
is right here we have all of these
functions of these three functions
and the combinator pattern allows us to
chain
all of these functions together so the
same way that you saw
with a function where we can use and
then and the same with predicates by
using
i think it was and right or or
we can have the same logic with the
combinator pattern
so right here what i'm going to do here
is the following so i'm going to have a
default
method and right here i'm going to
return a customer valid
data so the same thing that we did here
and then i'm going to say and right so
right here we're going to take
a customer valid data and then i'm going
to call other
so basically this is where the magic
happens right
so i'm going to say other and
inside i'm going to return and then
customer
and then inside what i'm going to do is
simply say
this dot and then apply
so we are going to apply this customer
and i'm going to shrink this to a
variable so i'm going to say result
and now check this out i'm going to say
return
and then result dot
equals and then success
so if it is equal to success i'm going
to apply the
other validator dot
and then apply and then customer
otherwise
i'm going to simply pass the actual
result not super result
there we go so if we get to this point
we know that we have an error
so now this is complaining because i
need to pass
semicolon right here so let's go ahead
now
and use this awesome interface so let's
go back to the
main method right here and
now let me simply comment this out and
let me simply add an add sign right here
or actually let me simply leave it as it
is
and then i'm going to show you exactly
all the errors so
now let's go ahead and simply say
customer or actually not here
um so
using combinator
pattern so right here let's go ahead and
use a customer
registration validator and then
dot and check this out so we have all of
these methods right
is an adult is email valid and is
phone number valid so let me go ahead
and simply start with
is a email valid right
but now what i want to do is the
following
so right here i'm going to say dot
and then check this out we have this
method so
and right here so this is the one that
we defined
so i'm going to say and and then let's
use the rest so
if i do if i press ctrl shift you can
see that we have
the other methods so is phone number
valid
dot and then and and then is an
adult there we go so
if i now add a static import
you can see that now this becomes much
much cleaner
so now we have
these three methods that we have chained
together the way that we use it is
simply by saying
dot and then apply and then pass
customer
there we go now if we extract this to a
variable
so result and let's go ahead and simply
say south
and then result so
now what i'm going to do here is say
if and then result
not equals to success
so success we're going to
throw so let's throw
so throw new illegal state exception
you could have your own exception but
for now let's go ahead and throw an
illegal state exception
and then the actual result
dot and then name
there we go and basically this will
actually
print out the same thing right here but
i want you to see the actual result
so let's go ahead and scroll up and
let's start with
a valid customer so at gmail and then
the phone number has to start with plus
and then zero
so if i go ahead and run this
there we go we have success right here
and
if i scroll up let's now check all the
validation that we have
so let me remove the add sign
and then run there we go
you see that email is not valid and
we've thrown an exception
right so email are valid so if i add
that back and if i remove it plus here
run this there we go
phone number not valid and if i had a
plus there
and let's make sure that this guy was
born
uh you know 2015
or this guy alice was born 2015
so which means that you know she's not
an adult
so if i run this
you can see that is not an adult
right and you can even customize your
exception that we throw by including the
name
or you know an id or anything like that
but basically now you can see the power
of the
combinator pattern so if you have
more stuff that you need to change to
this validation so let's say that the
requirements
change you can simply duplicate this and
then
have your customer implementation inside
of the
interface that we've defined defined so
this one right here so customer
registration validator and then just
chain all the validation logic and
scenarios that you have
and this is the power of the combinator
pattern
so one last thing that i want to show
you is that so if i uh
command z a couple of times there so
basically
so right here you see that we call dot
apply
so if i comment this
and then right here let me simply remove
the apply there
so the cool thing about you know these
functions so let me change the variable
right here
to a validator so the cool thing about
this right is that this is
lazy right none of this stuff is
run until we invoke the dot apply
so if i say result right here you see
that we have
all of these methods right we can
compose apply so on and so forth
but if i run this
you can see that nothing gets printed
out and even if i
for example right here so where we um
return here so the email
value so right here so is email valid so
let me grab that and then let me simply
south
and then running email validation
and then right here simply return that
and end up with semicolon there so even
if i run
this you can see that we
still get nothing but as soon as i
uh referred all of this
just like that and then call apply
now check this out if i run
you can see that we have the running
email validation
and i think i need to undo all of this
and then run it again
and there we go so running email
validation right and then we have
is not an adult and the actual exception
so i hope that you see the power of the
combinator pattern
i use it whenever i can to perform
validation like this and you should also
do it if you have any questions go ahead
and drop me a message
otherwise let's move on
all right so in this final section let
me go ahead and explain you few things
that
will help you to fully understand the
functional interfaces and functional
programming
with java so so go ahead and create a
new package and
in this package we're going to call it
as
final and then section right here
so inside create a main method
and then so let me put this full screen
like this
and then ps and then vm
for public study void main and
right here what i'm going to do is i'm
going to write some javascript
and there we go so what i want to touch
on
this video is callbacks so
maybe you've done some javascript and
javascript they have
this notion of callbacks so a
function in javascript looks like this
so this won't work in java but it looks
like this
so you have a function and then you give
it
a name so hello
and then right here you might have for
example a variable so let's say
and then first name
last name and then
call back something like that right
so right here what we're going to do is
let's say for example
the last name is not provided then we
simply have like
console.log so let's simply say
console.log
and then right here uh first
and then name and then i can say
if if we have last name
then we're going to console.log
and then last name
otherwise we will have this callback so
we're going to
invoke the callback right so you might
have seen code like this in javascript
basically this is an extra function so
if i take
this command c and then go to
chrome and then inspect and then right
here go to console
paste my function there and then enter
you can see that we have undefined now
if i say hello
and then say first name john
and then pass now there and then right
here i can pass
a function so this is a callback right
so console
dot and then log and then no
last name provided
and then end this with a parenthesis
here
if i now run this oops we have
a error there and they should shouldn't
have the column there
so enter and you can see that now we
have
john and then no last name provided
so basically you can see that this
callback right here is a function and
you can have like you know
a lot of logic in it right but
you know this is very simple so we're
just logging but if you want to have for
example
an extra logic that goes to the database
and there's
you know some other stuff you could
definitely do it i'm just
showing you the callbacks in javascript
so right here
if i now pause so right here if i now
say alex and then montana
and then run this you can see that now
we're not printing the actual callback
right so now we have john
and then montana the last name so we can
achieve the same
in java using functional programming and
the functional interfaces so the way
we're going to do it is as follow
so let me simply comment this right here
so you have it for reference
so now what i'm going to do is actually
have a static
and then void and right here what i'm
going to do is actually combine
both worlds so we can have a
regular method so normal java method
and also inside as a parameter we can
have a function
right so this is you know programming
because now we are free to do whatever
we want
so right here you see static void and
then let's go ahead and simply say hello
and then right here string and then
first and then name string
last and then name and then right here
what do you think we need right so
remember we've learned about functions
by function consumers suppliers
predicates so we kind of just
want to have a function
that might take for example last name if
it's there
printed otherwise have for example a
default message
so right here what we're going to do is
simply say consumer
and then of type and then string
and then let's simply name this as call
back
just like that there we go and then
right here let me simply say
south and then first name
and then i want to say if and then
um last name
equals to no right we could even say
is blank right but equals to null so if
it's equal to null or actually let's
revert this
so it's the same as the function that we
have right here as javascript
so if it's not equal to no let's go
ahead and say south
and then a last name otherwise
else we're going to say call back
dot and then accept and then the string
that we want
is first name for example right so let's
take
this first name right here and then do
something with it
so now the way we use it is as follow so
let's go ahead and
say hello and then john
right here and then montana
and right here let's have our callback
so let's go ahead and simply pass now
for now
right so if i run this
there we go you see that we have john
montana but now let's
go ahead and define this callback so
right here
we'll have um a callback
that takes a value and the value will be
the actual
first name it doesn't matter and then we
will do something with it so right here
south and then what did we have
so right here we said
last name not provided so let's do the
same here
and then four and then
plus and then john and then value
right so you could even you could even
change this to
first name if you want but i'm just
going to leave it as value
now if i run this
you see that we have john montana but
now watch this
if i pass no right here
and then run
there we go no last name provided for
john
so basically i just want to show you
that you can combine
you know a normal function with
these functional interfaces and do stuff
like this
and achieve a similar concept
as javascript that they call callbacks
so there are other languages that have
the similar
concept but javascript you see a lot of
these callbacks being thrown and you can
pretty much do the same
with functions another way that you
might see callback
is so right here so because right here
you might not want to pass
a default value right so you might have
something like this
so right here let me just duplicate this
and then call it two and then right here
so i'm gonna simply
remove this and then runnable
and this will be the callback and then
right here
call back dot and then run right so this
is a bit different now
so right here the way we use it is
simply say hello
like here and then two and then right
here
you simply pass this runnable right here
and you have no
value there basically this now is the
exact same thing
as this concept right here right
because we're not taking any value and
because
um i only have one line there i can
simply do this
and then check this out just like that
and
beautiful code so now if i run this
you see that it's the exact same thing
but right here we're not taking
any arguments so there we go so
this is how you combine both worlds
where you can mix and match
these functional interfaces with normal
functions and have
callbacks if you have any questions go
ahead and drop me a message
otherwise let's move on
let me go ahead and teach you about
lambdas so
we've been using lambdas throughout this
course
with you know all these functions but
basically let me show you exactly how
they're used
and for example if you only have one
return statement if you have two
arguments
what you should do uh when using lambdas
so let's go ahead and expand
this so commanded n1 and right here
for this main method let me go ahead and
simply name this as
callbacks just like that
now let's go ahead and create a new
class and then simply call it as
lambdas there we go
oops not lambers but lambda
and then this just like that
now let me collapse that and then public
static
void main now inside let's go ahead and
have
a function there we go that takes a
string
and returns a string there we go
so let's simply say uh print
and then name equals two so this guy
will take
name and then right here so
this part right here it's a lambda right
so this
is a lambda where this is the actual
argument right so this name right here
is what comes from this data type
so right here then you have to pretty
much just
uh do the following so if you have only
one line so if you simply return
immediately
you can simply do this so south
and then well actually not even south my
bad
so you can simply and this is not a good
example so not print
name but let's simply say
um upper and in case
name for example something like this
right so now right here if you simply
return
immediately you can simply do this
so name and then dot and then uppercase
right so you can immediately do this
so this is only when you have
one return statement right after
this um um error right here
so because you only have one return
statement
and you can even see that intellij is
telling you that you can use a method
reference so this is because
right here this is the same as doing
this
right it's the exact same thing so
this is more understandable but you know
once you get
too comfortable with this you'll start
to use code like this
now another thing is right here so
if you have to do some extra logic and
not return
immediately you need to have these curly
braces right here
so now you can have a logic right so you
can for example say
if and then name dot
um or actually is blank right here
so if it's blank then you can throw
new illegal and an argument exception
something like this right and then right
here
otherwise now because
i need to return i need to say return
and then name to uppercase but also i
need to
add semicolon right here
right so you can see that now this is
the actual
method body for this lambda right so
this lambda so this is the entire thing
right here
so another thing that you could do with
lambdas is you see right here
where you have name so if this is a by
function
so by function uh just like that
and then right here let's simply have um
let's have an integer right here integer
and this will be
h right so now you see that
i need to put age right here because
this data type is for
this one and this data type is for the
second one
right and string is what this by
function returns
now because i have two arguments i need
to do this
i need to enclose them within these
parentheses
so let me actually go back for a second
so right here so where we have a
function
so you see this is a function i can even
you know enclose them
with parentheses but because i only have
one argument right
into this function right here i can
simply ditch
this right but if you have a
by function
and right here let's simply say integer
again
and then age now you need to enclose
like that right and
you could you know do something like
another logic right here so south for
example
and then h something like that right
and you know the way you'd use it is as
follows
so uppercase name dot
apply and then alex let's have alex here
and alex is 20 right there we go and
this returns a
string right here upper
case name
and then south then uppercase name
i can even in line this like so
if i run this
there we go so 20 and then alex
so basically this is uh this logic
doesn't really make sense but i just
want to show you exactly
different ways that you can use these
lambdas right here
so if you have any questions on lambdas
go ahead and drop me a message
otherwise let's move on
all right so just to let you know that i
think i didn't mention this at the
beginning of this course
but when you use these functional
interfaces
you see right here where you define the
actual inputs and
outputs of functions right so string
and an integer and then string so
these right here they have to be the
object type
and not the primitive so for example
integer
right so you could have an integer like
this
so integer and then number
equals to no right
and then you can also have integer and
then let's say counter
and right here i can't say this
so this is invalid right because this is
the primitive
um version of this
object type right here right so right
here you either have to say
a number so it could be negative number
or positive number
so if i do a zero right here you could
see that this goes away
so for that reason you are not
allowed to have primitives in
here right because if you have to pass
nose then then you can
so with primitives you cannot so
right here you see that we have this
integer right here
so i can go ahead and simply say no
right here and you see that works
but if i was to have this integer so the
primitive type
that does not work and
also one thing that i've been doing a
lot throughout this course
is having static right here so static
so the reason why i've been doing static
is because i'm outside
so right here i'm outside of the
main function and the main function is
static right and you can only use
static methods inside of this main
function
so right here you can see that this
still works but if i remove the static
keyword
you can see that it does not work
right so this is something that to bear
in mind uh your functions and buy
functions they
don't have to be static right in fact
having static throughout your code base
is not practical so ideally what you
would do
is simply have for example
so let's say that you have a class let
me actually um
put this inside so just like that
so let's say that you have a class
and then call this a service for example
right
what you should really be doing is like
having uh you know
publix and then your function for
example
or predicate
or consumers right so consumer
of string and then blur
[Music]
equals two and an
s right just like that
and then basically this is your public
interface
you can also change this to private or
no access modifier at all so this is
package protected
right so just to bear in mind that
you know they don't have to be static
and you should avoid static but the
reason why i've been using static
is because i've been doing everything
inside of this
public static void main method
so there we go if you have any questions
on primitives
and the use of solid keywords go ahead
and drop me a message
otherwise catch me on the next one
all right let me go ahead and quickly
show you the rules that come with
functional programming and everything
that we've learned
throughout this course so the first
thing i should know
is that um there should be
no state around your
functions right so the functions they
have to be
pure functions so they shouldn't depend
on any other state so for example if you
have a global state
like or a global variable your function
should not depend on that global state
right so that's the difference between
pure and in pure
functions so pure functions don't
depend on global state impure functions
do depend on global state
and that comes with the side effects
right
so your functions should have no side
effects
other than everything inside of the body
of your function right it shouldn't have
a side effect
outside of the function and also
higher order functions so a function
is considered to be higher order
function
if one of these two conditions are met
the function takes one or more functions
as parameters so we saw how to
so we saw how to pass functions inside
a normal functions right or
if the function returns another function
as result so with the combinator pattern
that's exactly what we've done so let me
actually show you
so right here so with callbacks so right
here
so right here so you can see that right
here we are passing
a function right here so this is a
function right
and also within our a combinator pattern
so remember so customer and then
registration
validator check this out so right here
we are returning a function
so this interface extends customer
who actually extends function that takes
a customer and sends a validation result
but if you check the return type of all
of these methods right here so if i do a
command shift and then minus you can see
that
they all return the function right here
so this means that we are satisfying
with this property higher order
functions
so make sure that
for example let me actually show you uh
you know the no state and pure functions
inside effect so
if i go back to let's say lambdas right
here
so you see this function right here so
int by function
right here so i should never depend
on for example counter right so let's
say that i do for example
south and then counter or if i
change the state of counter right
i should never do this because it will
break
all of this right so you see that there
might be some side effects
on the outside of this function right
here
right so outside of this function there
might be
there's some side effects also you see
that
you are now mutating state
and it's no longer a pure function it's
an impure function because
it depends on um
global state so you never want to do
this or for example increment the number
so
number and then you know increment um
you know plus plus something like that
you should never do it
right so your functions right here
they should be self-contained right
so they should only depend on the state
that you define
inside so right here i could say in inc
and then counter
equals to zero so this is absolutely
fine
right because this counter
so this counter right here it's only
visible
inside of this function and not the
outside world
so if you have any questions on these
properties
go ahead and drop me a message and i can
give you more examples
but this is pretty much everything
you need to know about functional
interfaces and functional programming
with java if you have
any questions go ahead and drop me a
message
next let's go ahead and wrap up this
course
okie dokie amigo i want to congratulate
you for completing this
course and practicing throughout so
as you saw for you to write functional
programming you just have to shift the
way that you
think you no longer think about regular
java functions
but you start to use functions by
functions
predicates consumers suppliers so on and
so forth
now the next step for you is to enroll
to my course
on java streams api because once you
combine
everything that you've learned in this
course with java streams
you will start to write code that really
really shines
instead of you writing code that takes
for example 20 lines of code
you simply take five lines of code with
streams and functional interfaces so
this is all for now go ahead and
subscribe to my channel to get more
videos like this
and it really means a lot to me to see a
lot of you
you know sending me messages suggesting
for new courses
and i'm trying my best to give you
awesome content
that will allow you to become a software
engineer
also if you haven't joined the private
facebook group go ahead
and join because that way you can see
what's up you can connect with all the
students
and if you have any questions just drop
them and i'm pretty sure
one of us will be able to help you this
is all for now
and i'll catch you on the next one see
ya
[Music]